thought it feels so good jerry let me
feel so good save me one time save one
more time show you the money say it with
me jerry
savage brother show you the money no no
no no let's talk you the money show me
the money let me do the same show me the
money voted terry show me the money let
jerry say louder show me the money
that's golden tate apparently he made
that the last time he signed a free
agent contract but it went largely
unnoticed it's everywhere now on social
media his homage to jerry maguire and
last time around he got five years 31
million from the lions now the giants
give him four years 37.5 million 23
million fully guaranteed for a receiver
on the wrong side of 30
and regardless of what the giants would
say because they'll say he's not the
replacement for otto beckham jr it's
going to look like he's the replacement
for odell beckham jr and it's only going
to make giants fans more salty than they
already were thinking that the giants
believe that they can backfill the giant
void left by obj with golden tate
and i this is nothing against golden
tate because i think golden tate's a
very good receiver i mean mike you know
from him being the nfc north for so many
years he he kind of killed everyone in
the nfc north he's always a big play guy
and you know not obviously he doesn't
stretch the field but i'm talking about
like makes big catches and big moments
he did it for the eagles against the
bears in the playoffs but this makes no
sense and it makes no sense because what
you just said odell beckham gets traded
on tuesday whether you whether this is
the odell beckham replacement or not
they will always be linked together and
the giants can't figure out what they
want to do
what their premise here now is they want
to win while also building a roster dave
gellerman said you can win while you
build a roster we do have a plan and
this is part of it
listen i just go with the gut test here
when you have to get in front of the
media and convince them that you do in
fact have a plan
chances are you don't have a plan
well i think the plan is this and the
plan well the the the the plan as it
relates to otto beckham jr dramatically
changed because surely the plan wasn't
let's keep him for one more year and pay
him over 21 million dollars and then
trade him when they could have traded
him a year ago but the broader plan is
tiptoe on eggshells around eli manning
that for whatever reason eli manning has
a lifetime pass with the new york giants
and i think it all goes back to when
former head coach ben mcadoo clumsily
tried to bench eli manning for geno
smith the fan base lost their mind and
now the giants ultimately fear the
reaction to when they decide to move on
from eli manning so their attitude is we
got to keep this guy for as long as he
wants to be here even if he's the last
one to figure out that it's time to go
all because of the two super bowls that
he won and the affection that the fans
have because i think the fans feel like
eli's a member of the family and how
dare you rip this guy away from us but
we've still reserved the right to say
that the team stinks it's a weird it's a
weird duality for a giants fan they
don't like the fact the team's no good
but don't you touch eli manning
and really i think ben mcadoo was ahead
of his time because when you look at the
giants what they were last year i don't
think the fan base would care as much
now if they said we're moving on from
eli manning the interesting thing that's
gonna happen here with the giants is now
they have the sixth and seventeenth pick
will they move up or will they try to
pick their quarterback at six and if
they do pick their quarterback what
happens mike what happens when that
quarterback let's call him dwayne
haskins shows up to mini camp shows up
to training camp and is a better
quarterback than eli manning and the
whole entire team says why are we
playing eli manning why are we going
with this guy when you guys told us the
plan is to win because my theory has
always been it is hard to intentionally
tank in the nfl because guys are playing
for their jobs it's a violent sport you
need to be out there giving your all you
can't say we're gonna try to lose games
like you can in the nba or maybe major
league baseball so if the giants draft a
quarterback now what's gonna happen when
that quarterback ends up being better
than eli manning you're now gonna
undercut your your coach and the whole
thing blows up for you
and that's how we're gonna find out more
about the plan whatever it is how they
use those two first-round picks if they
take a quarterback with either of those
picks then the plan is build for the
future if they package the two picks
together and move up to get to try to
get a kyler murray and they met with
murray the other night after his pro day
workout and they reportedly aren't
interested in him because he's not big
enough he doesn't fit the mold but you
know what if they fall in love with him
they should do what they have to do to
go get him but that's when we'll know
what the plan is and and you're right
they're asking for trouble if they try
to do the kc model and at the scouting
combine that was the talking point that
everyone from the giants was putting out
the kc model draft a guy who sits for a
year while eli manning is here they said
it so much i wonder whether or not it's
the truth i think they're trying to to
misdirect their competitors while also
making the fans think they have a plan
we do have a plan dave gettleman said
that if you have to say that you don't
take our word for it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports